[Music]
hey what's up mkbhd here
and this is the iphone 12. i feel like
we've all seen an iphone before at this
point this is a pretty familiar iphone
we've seen the rounded corners and the
notch
and the lightning port but there are a
couple key changes
this year that are a first in the iphone
so i've been using this iphone 12 for a
bit
since my impressions video and it's my
favorite iphone ever
mostly because of this design but
if you're considering getting one
there's some stuff you should know now
i'm going to do a separate video on
the pro in this sweet blue color i think
it's the best color but
these two phones are very similar same
exact size like a case that works for
one
works for the other same main cameras
almost the same screen
same battery same charging but there's a
couple things that only apply to the pro
and i'll go over those in that video but
let's just start with the 12
with this new design shall we i love
this
super flat design it is so flat it's not
the typical
almost flat where the screen is flat
right up to the edges and then it curves
over the very edge and they call it like
2.5 d
no this is flat flat like the phone
happens to be a little bit thinner and a
little bit lighter than last year but
i'm not as concerned with that but the
square sides
are actually the most efficient way to
pack in those internals into the phone
as efficiently as possible
and i happen to think it looks and feels
super premium and modern
on top of all that now this kind of red
but also kind of salmon sometimes
product red version
after seeing it in person i'd probably
not go for this i'd go for either the
blue
or the black but yeah those aluminum
rails
are everything they're more grippable
maybe a little
less comfortable at first but hey the
buttons are clicky
the power button is a little bit bigger
it's still ip68 water resistant
you've got your 5g antenna cut out on
the right hand side in some regions
which trust me i'll get way into that in
a second
and yeah i just like holding this phone
now if you put a case on it i guess a
lot of that doesn't matter as much
you'll notice it less obviously but
still even some cases
are flattening out their dimensions for
the iphone 12 so
that again will make it easier to grip
harder to drop
and speaking of dropping all these new
iphones come with
on the front something new called
ceramic shield
and this is basically this specialty
hardened
kind of glass with crystal structure
inside it and it's on the front of these
phones over the screen
and it's supposed to offer four times
better drop protection
so shatter protection basically which is
great
but i typically care just as much if not
more about
scratch resistance all the little micro
scratches that your phone gathers over
time
and the thing about scratch resistance
is it's typically inversely proportional
to shatter resistance so if you think
about it the softer something is the
less likely it is to shatter but then
the easier it is to scratch it
and vice versa the harder something is
the less likely you are to scratch it
but the more brittle it is and the more
shatterable it becomes so i see the
headline of
better drop protection and that's great
but i'm not about to drop my phone to
find out if it works
i'm sure people are already on that i
have no idea how they'll land on that 4x
number but all right
all i know is i already have a little
gash in my screen
on the left hand side here which is so
sad but that's
probably out of level six no idea how
that happened
but i'm feeling like the iphone is not
significantly more scratch resistant
than before
of course zach will probably tell us the
truth there so if it shatters a lot less
when dropped
we'll see that would be nice but i feel
like a lot of the drop stuff
is happenstance like if i happen to drop
my phone
a certain way it's definitely gonna
crack right and if i happen to drop my
phone another way it's
probably not going to so i don't know i
don't want to worry about too much
use the case if you want to use a screen
protector if you really want to
i'm just going to i'm just going to live
my life
[Music]
so possibly the biggest external
hardware feature of the new iphones
is magsafe and i think it has bigger
implications for the future of the
iphone but right now
magsafe is the optional new magnetic
charging accessory standard on the back
like right behind
the apple logo so the number one magsafe
accessory that apple sells
is the puck charger it doesn't come with
a brick
by the way so if you buy the charger 40
bucks make sure you have a usbc
charging brick but uh yeah just kind of
slaps onto the back of the phone
you line it up with the magnets you kind
of get used to where it places right
over the apple logo
and that's all good this charges at 15
watts while every other wireless charger
on the iphone still charges at seven and
a half watts
and a couple other faqs on this number
one yes it is still
qi charging so you can still charge the
iphone 12 with other wireless chargers
and you can charge other phones with the
magsafe puck if you're into that
number two the durability concern with
magsafe leaving marks on the iphone
i have noticed that on mine too but
i don't think it'll turn out to be a
long-term problem it just seems to wipe
off every time like you might remember
how the homepod was leaving
these little white stained rings on
certain wood tables which is
kind of understandable because not every
table is the same
but i feel like i guess i hope apple's
probably tested
this like a hundred thousand times and
probably
determined that it's not an issue about
the way they made this
so should be okay and then number three
i was getting a lot of questions about
this
yes you can magsafe charge through most
non-magsafe cases as long as they're
thin enough and even that magnet will
actually still work
through some thin cases so i didn't
really have any non-magsafe cases here
to test
but of course channel sponsored dbrand
sent over a grip case and i can confirm
it's thin enough to work just fine with
a magsafe charger kinda like it is a
magsafe charger
and yes all the other benefits of a case
grippiness
protection they all still apply so since
i know most people end up looking for a
good one
i'll leave a link to this case below now
at the beginning of this magsafe bit i
said something
i said it was optional which
it is for now but i feel like we can all
sort of see where this is going which is
apple is slowly moving towards
eventually making
a portless iphone which i think that's a
whole
separate video's worth of rant but
bottom line is their solution to
wirelessly conveniently charging a phone
that doesn't have a port
is going to be magsafe this thing right
here so
it's not amazing but i guess it's fine
the couple of accessories they've made
for it
so far not bad there's a regular case of
course that you can continue to stack
things through
there's a kind of weird-looking clear
version of the case for some reason
there's a wallet that i mentioned that
doesn't have very strong magnets
but if you think about it it's not so
peculiar that the one accessory they
chose to make
outside of a case is a wallet like let
me know if there's any flaw in this
this series of logic right so apple
wants to get rid of the port on the
iphone and go
totally wireless charging for everything
at a certain point maybe next year
whatever
right so they already see ahead of time
this particular headline which is people
who use wallet cases
can't wireless charge their iphone so
they can't charge the iphone at all
so apple needs to invent a way for
people who use wallet cases
to continue to charge their phone so
they invent an accessory which is a
removable wallet bit
so you can charge the phone and when you
don't need to charge it you can put the
wallet back on
that seems to check out like i said it's
a whole thing
but today optional battery life on these
phones has actually been
pretty good but not noticeably better
than last year at all
matter of fact it's actually a slightly
larger higher res display
and actually a smaller physical battery
so it's pretty impressive that the phone
still does
okay you can kill it in a day with six
hours of screen on time
or just a lot of heavy use but this
isn't new with this standard size iphone
if you want a real battery champ you can
go for the bigger phone
the actual best new piece of the iphone
12 though
is definitely the new display it goes
from being that 720p
lcd with bigger bezels that was really
easy to make fun of to this much better
and even slightly bigger 6.1 inch 1080p
oled
it's like night and day it's basically
on par with the pro
which is actually pretty surprising to
me just a slightly lower peak brightness
now it's 60 hertz again and while that's
kind of
a missing feature at this point on an
800 phone in 2020
i was actually kind of expecting that i
was just thinking the pros
would get 120 hertz displays this year
but obviously none of them did which is
a bummer
but let's be honest they probably saw
that as a battery saving measure
since this phone did also just get 5g
so let's talk about 5g i kind of
love and hate 5g right now so this
slogan
apple and i guess the carriers 2 really
keep pushing that 5g
just got real 5g just got real really
just now 5g just now got real last time
i checked
like this year i reviewed like 30 phones
with 5g
so clearly 5g has already existed
but there's a reason they're saying it
this way so first of all i did a video
all about 5g where i went to a 5g area
testing it explaining it showing what's
good about it and what its limitations
are
i'm going to leave it linked right below
the like button if you want to watch it
catch up on that but the bottom line is
it's
really promising but it's still being
built right now but carriers
and i guess apple really like the
message that 5g
just got real because now that all of
the new iphones have 5g
built in there's about to be millions
and millions and millions more
people walking around with 5g capable
phones in a few very short months
and when that happens that tends to
accelerate development that sort of
makes it real which i get it but also
the carriers would very very much like
you to upgrade to their 5g
plan please but we got to remember 5g in
2020
has its ups and its downs like this
iphone 12 i'm using here has
verizon 5g which is surprisingly
actually in my area it's not millimeter
wave it's not ultra wide band
but it can still give me roughly 20
faster download and
upload speeds but 5g radios are also
pretty power hungry and the more time
you spend on 5g
the more battery you bleed through now
apple's thought a lot about this of
course so
their solution and you might have caught
it on stage during the announcement
is called smart data mode and basically
it tries to only use 5g
when you actually need it to save
battery so when you're in a 4g area
you're on 4g speeds everything works
with lte
no problem you're good it'll feel normal
when you're in a 5g
area and you're doing a lot of bandwidth
intensive stuff you're downloading a
bunch of videos and music
you're face timing and crispy hd you're
doing a lot of that
high bandwidth stuff that's going to use
5g and that's going to improve that
experience a lot but if you are in a 5g
area but not really doing anything that
benefits from 5g
then your phone will actually switch off
and stick with 4g and as the verge
reported it'll actually still
show you the 5g indicator in the corner
but
you'll get 4g speeds which we'll
probably find but that also explains
this sort of weird speed test result so
look my take is
i get it the best technologies are
supposed to be
invisible like you shouldn't even notice
they work you go to download something
while walking around
you're in a 5g area boom 5g turns on
your downloads go super quick and then
it turns off to save battery
kind of like promotion on the ipad pro
it goes
up to 120 hertz when you're scrolling
and playing games and actually using it
but when you're not you're just sitting
on the home screen or watching a video
it will go down to 24 hertz to save
battery
so it's sort of not there when you don't
need it it's there when it helps you
it's just weird that the whole messaging
has been in your face
5g 5g 5g 5g
5g so yeah i would say don't buy this
phone
now because you want to get a 5g phone
but if you do get this phone now then
maybe it'll be a nice bonus if you're in
a 5g
area or in the future when you end up in
a 5g area you'll be able to use that too
cool
[Music]
all right new iphone equals new best
camera ever in an iphone right
well sure iphone 12's got a slightly
updated dual camera system
with a standard and an ultra wide the
standard has a slightly wider aperture
at f 1.6
instead of f 1.8 and to be honest
it's not really much of a difference in
the camera like it's just not
same as the pixel they're not really
doing anything too drastic
if it ain't broke don't fix it really
the hardware improvements are
almost impossible to notice in regular
photos but they will get you an
improvement in like the edge cases the
most difficult photo
and video taking scenarios so like
handheld in low light that'll be better
night mode will be better auto focus on
fast moving subjects
super high dynamic range shots like
shooting straight into the sun
thanks to smart hdr3 stuff like that
other than that
it still looks like iphone photos which
is to say some of the absolute best
and most consistent crisp photos on any
smartphone so that's not a letdown but
iphone video though
firmly in a league of its own it firmly
like every time i test a new iphone
camera
it's just the video camera is so much
better and people care a lot about video
they take a lot of videos so you'd want
to know
yeah the iphone takes great video and
that's despite not shooting 8k
and not having a huge new sensor or
anything crazy like that it's just so
fine-tuned and so reliable but i want to
save my full analysis of that for the
video
about the pros because i think pros care
even more about video stuff
and there's potentially well there's
even new hardware
of the sensors in the 12 pro max so that
could be interesting to see my one knock
is it does seem like there's more
flaring in low light video like just a
ton of little orbs for every little
point light source
but it's still very usable though now
you might have heard about dolby vision
hdr these new iphones are the first
cameras the only cameras in the world to
shoot
bit high dynamic range dolby vision 4k
video
and that's awesome hdr video is awesome
higher brighter brights
deeper shadows overall better images
even better perceived quality
i love hdr but here's the thing dolby
vision is just
one hdr standard or format
by dolby and there are other hdr
standards that have been out you might
heard of
hdr10 is one of them and that some other
smartphones have actually started
enabling you to shoot you might have a
smartphone in your pocket right now
that is already capable of shooting
hdr10 video but the issue with new
formats
is always compatibility so some tvs are
hdr10 certified
some aren't some displays are adobe
vision certified some aren't
so you can look at the display the video
you take on the iphone
and it's dolby vision certified and it
looks amazing and if you send this video
to another iphone 12 it'll look amazing
on that iphone but as soon as you upload
it to
twitter or instagram or tick tock or
kinda anything at this point even
youtube
it doesn't show up as that hdr on most
people's screens
it's back to sdr but the big deal here
again
is kind of like 5g because there's about
to be so many
iphone 12s in the world there's about to
be millions of new devices and new
people out there
shooting tons of hdr video and looking
to share it and so now there's more
incentive for places and
and apps like twitter and instagram and
tick tock
to support hdr so
maybe the tagline should have been hdr
just got real
anyway the rest of the iphone is pretty
familiar and that's a good thing for
most people
ios 14 we've all seen it by now it's
familiar even though there's
a couple bugs and apps that will
probably get updated pretty soon
face id it's completely unchanged even
performance
is familiar since there's nothing super
new like high refresh rate
there is the new a14 bionic inside which
is one of the very first five nanometer
chips in any device
which is a more powerful cpu and gpu and
is paired with 4
gigs of ram and everything's great but
that's mainly for speed that you're
going to notice
later down the road when the phone is 2
3 4 years old and hopefully still
feeling really fast but fundamentally
there isn't really that much of a
difference
in these iphones and the performance you
get this year versus what last year
didn't already do
just a little bit faster but yeah even
at a somewhat premium
830 bucks that's the actual price
apple's website shows carrier pricing at
first so it's a little misleading but
even at that price
yeah this phone with best in class
cameras best in class performance
much better screen is pretty damn good
it's this is the one to get for most
people here's a too long didn't watch
version for those of you lazy people
that i know just went down to the
chapters and skipped to this
it's a great phone the best new parts of
it are definitely the display
which was a huge knock up from last year
knock up
why'd i say it like that the display is
better battery life's about the same
cameras are a little bit better build
quality and design are also an awesome
improvement and magsafe
it's optional for now but might as well
start getting used to it
and the worst part is the price is a
little higher because also
5g is built into the phone even for
people who are never going to use it but
that being said
there you have it great work apple and
definitely stay tuned for the review on
the pro i want to dive into what
makes it a pro you know as a as a
youtuber i think a lot about this as a
content creator am i a pro iphone user i
don't know there's a lot to talk about
there but
that's been the iphone 12. thanks for
watching much coming up
very soon because you know tech toby
guys
it's over catch you guys in the next one
[Music]
back peace and on and on